ragazzi se per caso qualcuno aveva la
domanda ma fa la vita prima di
registrare video come ti prepari
ecco questa è la risposta
[Musica]
tutti ragazzi e benvenuti questo video
sono fa dj ed oggi siamo nuovo blog
prima di tutto a ricominciare come al
solito con l'apparato della settimana
che questa settimana è stata vinta da
francesco che ragazzi ha fatto diventare
una fan art
sull'attacco dei giganti dove in
versione kit mario meraviglioso sopra
per l'originalità di sta cosa perché
perché come idea è una delle più belle
che abbia mai visto finora e talaltra
negazione delle primissime volte che
vince un maschio cosa incredibile perché
anche noi sappiamo di segnare dobbiamo
farci vedere infatti ragazzi per questo
che ho disegnato è un è un cervo questo
significa che anche noi noi ragazzi
sappiamo sappiamo disegnare che andiamo
avanti come prima di usare che volevo
ringraziarvi per uno speciale 750 mila
iscritti perché ho visto che vi è
piaciuto tantissimo 60 mila mi piace ma
che cazzo ci non credevo addirittura
così tanto legati ai ragazzi che il
primo è possibile senza senza dirmelo
far uscire un montaggio bonus con le
tipiche non usato nell'altro così spero
siete contenti ragazzi almeno non lo so
che cosa può uscir fuori ma lo faccio lo
stesso la santa la news un po più sei
ragazzi mi volevo dire che nello scorso
blog che ho fatto un anno e mezzo fa
avevo detto rega che ho aperto un
profilo widget per cercare di rispondere
il più possibile di voi anche quando non
sono a casa di stato bloccato al profilo
dowie chat per che ricevevo troppi
messaggi
e siccome ragazzi questa notizia ha
sconvolto mezzo mondo ho deciso di
aprire un secondo un secondo profilo di
omicidi ragazzi se volete scrivere su
ichat il profilo non è più quello
dell'altra volta ragazzi ma è questo che
vedete qui sotto così almeno ci mettiamo
d'accordo e questo non me lo chiudono
perché per niente l'ho fatto diciamo
ufficializzare in modo tale che possa
ricevere messaggi più in quantità
industriale così almeno potrò tentare di
utilizzare il mio cellulare come bomba
nucleare nella prossima guerra mondiale
perché esploderà un pochettino di
notifica ma non importa
l'ultima cosa ragazzi poi possiamo oltre
promesso come sapete tutti i ragazzi è
finita la scuola
ma questo vale per voi perché per il
povere gli stronzi come me gli orgogli
esami porca [ __ ] e quindi ragazzi io
la scuola la finisco più o meno verso
fine giugno per che definisco esami a
fine giugno e siccome per avevo già
detto comunque nei blog anche precedenti
durante l'arco di giugno farò molti meno
video di quanti ne faccio di solito
ragazzi per chiedevo dove appunto
studiare per gli esami
una volta finito giugno ragazzi vi
prenderò come avevo già detto un anno
intero di pausa perché sono distrutto in
un modo che non avete idea è che stanno
ragazzi far uscire almeno un video al
giorno a volte anche di più se riesco
quindi non vedo l'ora dovete per la
mente resistere sto mese ragazzi poi è
fatta praticamente è detto che esse
ragazzi direi che siamo a posto dire che
mi sono passare allo scarto dei pacchi
[Applauso]
fino a 30 kg e sti cazzi allora io non
apro un centro di body building non è
possibile da volta pro tre pacchi che
però sono pacchi della madonna nel caso
ve ne foste accorti e di levi partire
dal più piccolo e vi potrà sembrare
strano ragazzi ma è proprio questo il
più piccolo ci sono legami oddio
santissimo sono 274 giochi per
playstation 3 ragazzi grazie mille e
meraviglioso legami che posso farlo
che cazzo i caduti ma anche al ct però
grazie mille vi prego ditemi che era
solo quello era solo qui tutti ma non
lui e [ __ ]
grazie per avermi regalato questa
splendida confezione di videogiochi ecc
e non potete illudere così un ragazzo ma
[ __ ] mi seppur acciaccato la carta la
io non so che cosa c'è qui dentro ma
promette benissimo ragazzi trovato un
serpente e non è neanche il peggio un
altro minion regate anche più bello di
colore l'altra volta
[Musica]
un super mario e umana grazie mille di
aprire l'ultima gara anche se
leggerissimo e cosa cazzo e starò lega
ho trovato un con questo mi calo giù
dalla finestra un cane da compagnia che
di sicuro mi fa più compagnia di quello
stronzo di un gatto prova bene è infine
salsa di soia
dopo aver scherzato sono due tipi e c'è
anche scritto sopra tipo di che gusto
stay stasera mi sembra sciroppo d'acero
ed era fortunatamente l'ultimo parco
ragazzi perché è giusto un po di carta
da buttar via adesso a questo punto
ragazzini e gli passerà il fa vi
risponde prima fatemi togliere questi
anni c'è un caldo boia già ok non ha
perso le orecchie meno ma
ma vaffan la prima domanda ragazzi mi
arriva da alberto che mi chiede poi
risponde ai giochi di compri online
se sì dove la maggior parte ragazzi dei
giochi che facciolini compro su steam
quindi quanti di voi mi chiedono anche
molto spesso fa viva da benché impresa
among the slip per dire ma regala 99 per
cento li trovate tutti su steam quindi
non c'è bisogno neanche che chiedete
marchio mi chiede fa vi risponde a farvi
visto e già 18 anni sai guidare la
macchina
andiamo a fare un giro
favi poi farò 740 video in cui giochi ad
outlast io mio santissimo che non
intendo fare risponde potreste andare su
google traduttore scrivere dei punti e
farli di leggere in giapponese si è
bravissima ma se tipo scriversi fa vj
spacca di brutto che cazzo mi legge vi
si spacca di hai diretto poi risponde
come gli avrei fatto fare la voce come
striscione pacifici e fa la mossa to
stop mostra una bella ragazza poi a loro
danno sono veloso un abbozzo stavamo
anno nuovo mi sento più intelligente
così e per ultimo come al solito direi
di passare alla favi domanda e voi non
chiede di ragazzi qual è il tipo di
speciale che vi piace di più nei
montaggi ogni gol roba con la nutella
cimenterà ragazzi qui sotto nei commenti
siamo lettera come sette ragazzi dire
che possono includere qui video quindi
se il video è giusto come stato lasciato
momento mi piace anche a pagani facebook
e come ogni video trovate nella
descrizione dove sedevano i siti
scrivete noi ci vediamo al prossimo
video bella ragazza